mold hair poop things you'd never allow
yourself to eat but according to the fda
you've probably been eating them for
years the united states food and drug
administration has identified levels of
179 natural or unavoidable defects in
food that are an acceptable risk to your
health let's take a look at the shocking
things that the fda allows on your plate
pee woo
the fda's food defect levels handbook
lists insect parts as the most common
defect in your food we're talking legs
wings thoraxes whole heads and brains
these insects show up in your frozen
fruit frozen broccoli frozen brussels
sprouts odds are anything that grows out
of the soil probably has some degree of
insect parts that accidentally get taken
in when the plants get harvested in the
case of items like cinnamon that get
ground into a powder the insects can get
ground in there too and while eating
those insects might not sound too
appetizing remember the fda deems it
poses no inherent hazard to your health
it could potentially give you a little
protein kick too the second most common
defect in american food is mold rot and
mildew and if you've ever let fruits or
vegetables sit too long on the table or
in the fridge then you know mold is
inevitable and is pretty easy to notice
blue cheese good mold shiitake mushrooms
technically good mold too but some mold
is quite dangerous and can actually
produce mycotoxins unfortunately mold is
common in something you may consume
every day coffee beans don't panic
though in order to pass the inspection
by the fda no more than 10 of beans in
any given count can be moldy and there's
an important note here while small
amounts of mold and foods monitored by
the fda is okay you should never eat a
piece of bread with even a small spot of
mold on it while you may think mold
exists in just that discoloration the
microscopic roots of that mold spread
throughout the entire item this is
unlike berries where you can throw away
the berry with the visible mold and
consume the other normal appearing ones
oh
i got bare hair in my mouth and speaking
of bear hairs rodent hair is the third
most common defect in our food it shows
up commonly in ground spices like
cinnamon curry oregano and nutmeg but
also in items like macaroni and cheese
peanut butter and popcorn literally the
fda says one road in hair per 100 grams
of peanut butter is a-okay i think if
you have a pet like i do we definitely
consume more hairs than that right bear
high five
probably the fanciest name on the list
mammalia excreta is the fourth most
common defect despite its latin name
mammalia excreta is not some high-end
perfume or university catchphrase it's
poop animal poop where there are animals
there is poop and you've most likely
been eating it i'm talking black pepper
cocoa beans even wheat i understand that
eating mammalian excreta is probably the
most disgusting thing you can think of
but just remember that manure or cow
poop is used to grow crops all around
the world so say it with me we all poop
and thank you poop this next one isn't
even so bad foreign matter this is a
random collection of all sorts of weird
little things that can slip into the
growth harvesting and shipping process
things like sticks from plants stones
from the earth burlap bag material from
transport and cigarette butts the fda
only allows up to one percent of the
weight of pickings and siftings of these
foods to contain foreign matter though
so it's really nothing you should
concern yourself about how about a tasty
bowl of babies that's right the fda
recognizes that is financially and
realistically impossible
to completely eliminate insect eggs
larvae and maggots from your food that's
why they allow up to five fly eggs per
500 grams of canned tomatoes two three
millimeter long larvae in canned corn or
10 insect eggs per 8 ounces of raisins
and i only thought people ate larvae on
fear factor we are so grateful to mother
earth for our food so we shouldn't be
too ungrateful to learn that she's left
a bit more of herself in there than
meets the eye the fda allows a small
amount of shells stems sand and pits in
our food you'll find pits and dates
olives and prunes shells with your nuts
stems in your cloves and sand in your
cumin again all very small amounts
there's probably some good fiber in
there anyway and finally it's time for
what i think is the most disgusting
defect the fda allows in our food
parasitic cysts it sounds gross when i
even say it a cyst is a sac that can be
filled with air liquid pus or parasites
a parasitic cyst is a sac that contains
the larvae or the baby version of a
parasite consumption of undercooked
meats and fish puts you at a higher risk
for developing parasitic infections like
worms in your gi tract complete
prevention of parasitic cysts from fish
is impractical as they are frequently
found inside the fish and therefore some
of those cysts inevitably wind up in our
seafood for example in whitefish the fda
allows up to 50 parasitic cysts per
hundred pounds that's why i recommend
you err on the side of caution and skip
that gas station sushi
lots of people ask me if it's dangerous
to hold in a sneeze i answer that
question here and more on this
responding to comments check it out as
always stay happy and healthy and be
careful with those sneezes watch that
video
just kidding gotcha
[Music]